I wonder if I can really use this?
[Music]
What are you doing?
[Music] Makabe: It's too
late. I seriously went to Africa. There were
a lot of things going on.
[Music]
Yoshino found the one in the back. I wonder if I can use it.  All you have to do is take it out. I'll
put it in the middle.
[Music] The
only problem is that it's cold, isn't it? Are you seriously planning to
spend the winter in this warehouse? Don't make a
mess, I'll take it out early. That's right,
Zebra-sama.
[Music] Just a
thank you.  Kane Iyemon
Of course
[Music]
Here, I'll give this to you. That's cool. Here's your
reward.
[Music]
Now we'll have some fried food and some rice balls. I'd
rather have salmon or cod roe. I have my own.
No, I need to eat more
Masamune used to be rounder. It
would be nice to conquer the donuts after school. Also, I
need you to drink the new drink. Hey, what kind
of fat plan is this? I
lost weight to get revenge on you.  Yes, it
was a misunderstanding, but there's no way I
can say that.The
new work is white.As
soon as the class is over, I'm sorry, but I'll refrain from doing so.Eh, that's
not a reward at all.No,
really,
just my feelings
are enough [Music]
music]